Traductor: Florencia Bracamonte
Revisor: Ciro Gomez
Mientras el guerrero dormía, una serpiente
se enroscó alrededor de su rostro.
Pero su esposa no la consideró
una amenaza sino un presagio:
un temible poder conduciría a su esposo
a la gloria o a la perdición.
Sin embargo, por el momento
él era simplemente un esclavo,
uno entre millones, capturados en
los territorios conquistados por Roma
para trabajar en las minas,
labrar los campos,
o luchar para entretener
así a la muchedumbre.
Nacido en Tracia, actual Bulgaria,
había servido en el ejército romano,
pero fue encarcelado por desertar.
Su nombre era Espartaco.
Espartaco fue trasladado
a Capua por Batiato,
un 'lanista' o formador de gladiadores.
Y la vida en el 'ludus', la escuela
de gladiadores, era inclemente.
Todo nuevo recluta
debía hacer un juramento:
"ser quemado, encadenado,
golpeado y muerto a hierro";
y obedecer la voluntad
del amo sin cuestionar.
Pero ni esta disciplina férrea
pudo doblegar el espíritu de Espartaco.
En el año 73 a. C., Espartaco
y otros 73 esclavos que lo siguieron
robaron cuchillos y broquetas
de la cocina y lucharon para escapar.
En el camino, interceptaron un vagón
cargado con armamento de gladiadores.
Ya no pelearían por otros;
ahora luchaban por su libertad.
Cuando la noticia llegó a Roma,
el Senado estaba muy ocupado con
guerras en España y en el Reino del Ponto
como para preocuparse
por unos esclavos revoltosos.
Impertérrito, Cayo Claudio Glabro
lideró un ejército de 3000 hombres,
se dirigió al monte Vesubio,
donde se refugiaban los rebeldes,
y bloqueó el único pasaje al monte.
Restaba únicamente esperar
a que se rindieran debido al hambre...
O eso fue lo que pensó.
En medio de la noche,
los rebeldes descendieron del
monte con sogas hechas de lianas,
y atacaron el campamento
desprotegido de Glabro.
Así nació la leyenda
del gladiador rebelde de Roma.
A medida que la rebelión
se hizo más conocida,
sus filas aumentaron
con esclavos prófugos,
desertores y campesinos hambrientos.
Muchos carecían de entrenamiento,
pero las ingeniosas tácticas de Espartaco
los convirtió en una verdadera guerrilla.
Una segunda expedición romana,
liderada por Publio Varinio,
fue emboscada cuando
los oficiales se bañaban.
Para evadir las fuerzas romanas restantes,
los rebeldes usaron los cadáveres
de sus enemigos como disfraz,
y hasta robaron el caballo
de Varinio para escapar.
Gracias a sus inspiradoras victorias
y a su política de distribuir
el botín equitativamente,
Espartaco continuó atrayendo adeptos,
y obtuvo el control de aldeas en
donde podían forjarse nuevas armas.
Los romanos comprendieron entonces
que no se estaban enfrentando
a unos simples fugitivos.
En la primavera del 72 a. C.
el Senado respondió enviando
dos legiones completas.
Los rebeldes resultaron victoriosos, pero
muchas vidas se perdieron en la batalla,
incluso la del teniente
de Espartaco, Crixo.
En su honor, Espartaco ordenó que
se llevaran a cabo juegos fúnebres,
en los que sus prisioneros romanos
debían luchar como si fueran gladiadores.
Hacia el final del año 72 a. C.,
el ejército de Espartaco era una fuerza
imponente de unos 120 000 soldados.
Pero semejante número
resultó difícil de controlar.
Con el paso hacia los Alpes despejado,
Espartaco pretendía marchar
fuera de las fronteras de Roma,
donde sus seguidores serían libres.
Pero su gran ejército
se había vuelto temerario.
Muchos querían seguir saqueando;
otros tenían la ambición de marchar
sobre la mismísima Roma.
Finalmente, el ejército
rebelde se dirigió al sur,
renunciando así a su última
oportunidad de ser libres.
Mientras tanto, Marco Licinio Craso había
tomado el mando de las fuerzas romanas.
Como era el ciudadano
más opulento de Roma,
persiguió a Espartaco
con ocho nuevas legiones,
y finalmente arrinconó a los rebeldes
en la península de Calabria.
Tras intentos fallidos de construir balsas
y luego de ser traicionados
por piratas locales,
los rebeldes intentaron
romper las filas de Craso,
pero no tuvieron éxito.
Los refuerzos de Roma regresaban
de las guerras mitridáticas,
y tanto las filas como el espíritu
de los rebeldes se habían quebrado.
En el 71 a. C., los rebeldes
presentaron su última resistencia.
Cuando estaba a punto de alcanzar a Craso,
Espartaco fue reducido por centuriones.
Su ejército fue destruido,
y 6000 prisioneros fueron crucificados
a lo largo de la Vía Apia
como muestra macabra
de la autoridad romana.
Craso ganó la guerra,
pero no es su legado
el que resuena en la historia.
Miles de años después,
el nombre del esclavo que hizo temblar
al imperio más poderoso del mundo
se ha convertido en un símbolo de
libertad y del coraje de luchar por ella.